hey guys it's Mary at e3 2016 and I am
here with Albert from pillow castle
that's correct
and you're gonna show me Museum of
simulation technologies today a game
that's truly something else quite unique
and I you know this is a puzzler game
but you tell me a little bit more about
it it looks like we're already right in
the middle of it yeah so this game is
this first-person puzzle game and
inspired by forced perspective so what
force perspective is is basically an
optical illusion where you use depth to
play interesting tricks and you can see
it when you you see a photo of somebody
taking a picture of the Leaning Tower of
Pisa and pretending to hold it up right
that's force perspective so in this game
you can take an object and based move it
around based on your perspective and
what the background is you can change
its size and its distance from you you
just taught someone right then because
that piece was in the way of the door
and you couldn't get through until you
move the piece exactly yeah so this game
is a lot about you know how we see
reality and how it can really play
tricks on us so a lot of the puzzles are
kind of like visual puns almost and yeah
so there's a lot of things you can play
around with but also a lot of unexpected
things that go around in this game and
one of my favorite parts about this game
is that it does these unexpected things
which is fun but it also has some kind
of internal logic to it right so you see
something that you think is one way and
then then this revealed it's totally
another thing but it kind of makes sense
it also looks like you're kind of
warping with the with the world here
like with the space of the room itself
it doesn't seem like this room should be
as big as it is it looks like you're
kind of manipulating the player a little
bit to get them to see things the way
you want them to are there it almost
seems also is that you've added an
element of comedy to it in the way that
you're training the player yeah that's
true we try to do comedy through kind of
subtle just gameplay moments and and we
found that I was just uh she's a really
interesting thing to play around with
right
trying to do comedy without words and
yeah and there's actually not a lot of
text in this game so this is a great
game for basically any language this is
kind of like a global appeal type game
yeah yeah exactly yeah we're hoping to
get some more narrative stuff in the
game at the in the future but this build
is is pretty empty so far now there's
not a lot of story or explanation you're
in a pretty weird hallway right now with
a bunch of doors that all have the same
number on it do you get a little bit
more of an understanding of what you're
doing in this world yeah over time the
world is kind of mystery that you start
with and in fact it's you're kind of
having this lucid dream right and you're
trying to basically wake up from it and
there's this whole mystery about what's
going on so I don't want to spoil too
much but there's some interesting stuff
that will happen later on in the game
and so you've already kind of
established the perspective concept and
manipulating the size what other things
you tend on teaching the player
throughout this game there's let's uh
this one's pretty cool too you're too
big
exactly yeah there's a lot cool stuff
that's coming up and and earlier
mentioned you know playing around with a
new shape and size things we're on the
inside look much larger than on the
outside and when the levels we play a
lot around with that concept and also
using things to change your own sizes
and stuff it just just goes to weird
places this game you're burning through
these puzzles probably because you might
have played them before once or twice
but how long would you say it would
actually take a player to get through
some of this usually players take take
quite longer I'm doing it a bit fast by
accident but what we're trying to do is
not let get players to be stuck on the
puzzles too much and you have kind of
the joy the joy of the game is not
figuring out exactly what you need to do
and not trying to know trying to solve
like a math problem or logical problem
but it's more like lateral thinking you
know so once you understand what the
solution of the puzzle is to actually
solve it should be relatively easy right
and that's a wonderful element of good
puzzle design is that the aha moment is
what you're searching for for people to
solve it this is kind of portal ask
right where you're you're getting them
to say this is what I was supposed to do
but the actual placement of the puzzles
or or the the portals but in your case
of the objects should be relatively easy
exactly yeah and at least for these
first few puzzles there's not too many
homes you have to worry about so it's
all about figuring out the concept
rather than the execution and how long
would you say that the entirety of your
game should take this should take about
let's say maybe three hours for a good
player and the longer if you take long
long time on the puzzles where you take
just you know wander around and walk
around more no I gotta touch on the
music of your game which is almost a
little silly in nature it's definitely
light-hearted where did you get it so
I'm I was listening to this type of jazz
music and it's called cool jazz it's
just like a very chill very kind of kind
of just nice sounding jazz and yeah so
so we just found some some people on the
internet who are doing licensed music
and then yeah that's what we used to
have the moment but eventually I'm
talking with this musician who's writing
actually new entirely new music just for
the game so that should be pretty
exciting you're actually gonna have new
music that's currently not not in it yet
that's it's being made but it'll be
around in this this style right
of course yeah there should be a lot of
interesting music there talking to you
what did that say this says just to just
do how to rotate objects in this level
okay oh so so this level is as one where
we're introduced kind of more weird
weird elements and
so at the first part of this this level
is like there's a lot of weird things
that kind of loop you back right and
we're trying to play with things that
are about you know looping and about how
how things repeat and weird way
sometimes it it's something we're
working on you're you're guiding the
player through these puzzles elements by
kind of like giving them hints as to
what's the next steps to get out of this
and looks like you were kind of trapped
in this room yeah I need to remember not
play through these puzzles too fast
before people understand what's going on
but but yeah so this is like this is the
loop that you can been going around
through until you realize that you need
to actually climb out a lot of the
puzzles focus on kind of like when you
see this thing that doesn't seem right
and then after a while you're like hey
maybe maybe I can do something else too
to change the situation right now here's
a new type of perspective now this is
about something that doesn't doesn't
actually hold its shape unless you look
at it from okay from a very particular
angle and now you actually can have the
object yeah exactly and we'd like to
change things up because there's a lot
of no whole perspective tricks you can
do just you know inside the real world
so we want to bring those elements into
the game I think it's great that you
aren't relying on the same mechanic each
time it looks like you're changing it or
adapting it and then building upon it
each time
yes exactly okay so this one is
interesting too if this plays a with our
perspective in two ways one is when grab
this thing down but then when we try to
you know climb up to this wrong we're
like oh it's too high and you certainly
look around this object and it turns out
you know things can have two sides that
are different than you are
okay so because that object was hollow
you were able to use it as stairs now
what prevents the player from just
taking that stairs with them everywhere
so in certain parts of the game you can
see this kind of wavy thing over the
doors and that's kind of to stop you
from taking items from one room to
another it's also kind of again like I
can't help but make the comparisons to a
portal game where it's um each room is
self-contained it's its own puzzle
element and what's really great about
that is as you go through this world you
basically take each room on its own
right and so you you can get not
frustrated but you can get stuck and
work on it but then once you get through
that room you're on a brand new puzzle
you refresh completely and you start
anew
right exactly and one of the games that
I'm most inspired from is also
antechamber if you've heard of that and
and an anti chamber they do a lot of
puzzles based off just playing around it
with players expectations so it kind of
took that and ran with it a bit more so
not only do you you know play with
players expectation by let's say
grabbing down the moon but there's also
things that you know end up kind of
making sense in a weird way yeah I
remember actually I also got a huge anti
chamber vibe from your demo I remember
Alexandre Bruce worked tirelessly on
giving players something to achieve
something that motivated them I remember
one of the things that he wanted to do
was basically say he showed a player a
gun much earlier through the game
through a window that said this is what
you want this is what you want to get to
what in your game would you say is
supposed to motivate the player to
continue on like what is what is the
thing that they are trying to achieve
here yeah the the main thing they are
trying to achieve here there's kind of
like an inherent mystery of what's going
on and you're always trying to find like
the exit of this game right and it's
always something that doesn't really
come about in the right way and it's
always like it's always like a head-fake
so players will always try to try to go
for and like at the beginning game we
show like that that Claire boot blue sky
and that's what you're trying to get to
right and it's kind of its kind of like
a weird dreamy thing but again another
antichamber connection will be the
non-euclidean world where you are
basically manipulating the space of your
reality so even though you were just in
a dollhouse now you're in a completely
new space yeah exactly and because we
have different we have that perspective
mechanic we can actually change the size
of of these houses while playing along
with a noncom Euclidean geometry and
that like brings us to really weird
places and this is no easy feat in terms
of design you must have a lot of work
into your level design to make sure this
is kind of working for the player how
many people are on your team well right
now the team is only two two people so
yeah where that's why the game is going
kind of slowly uh antichamber was a
one-person team but I believe that game
took him several years and I could chunk
of like his life to make your you've
been working on this for two years and
how much longer do you think you have to
go we're saying you know one and a half
years but it might be longer it's hard
to say but we're hoping it won't take
seven years it won't be another
antechamber yeah I can really take it
out of you and oh now you're in a
completely new space with a new puzzle
here looks like you can make the stairs
big but can you make them big enough
yeah that's the question but so that's
stuff that's obvious puzzle but then
like changing it up again and kind of
like changing the the player and that
looks like that's the end of your demo
yeah I'm sorry I'm playing through that
a bit quickly but now you know I've
saved you some time yeah it's a really
good overview of what's to come in this
game it absolutely looks fascinating and
I love how much you're guiding the
player and yet letting them figure out
these puzzles on their own this is a
really exciting game so where can people
find them you can check us out on our
website
paula kassig Gamescom besides that you
know the usual Twitter Facebook will try
to reply stuff with send us stuff yeah
and where can people eventually find the
game oh okay
that's a good question huh so we're
hoping to do PC Mac and we're hoping to
do at least one the consoles but
hopefully both both Xbox and Playstation
and it might be staggered based on the
size of your team but most certainly
you'll probably be able to find this on
Steam yeah exactly
all right well that was Museum of
simulation technology and you guys will
be able to see that hopefully and not
too long yeah maybe a year and a half or
so yeah all right well thank you so much
for showing me that Albert thank you all
right and for the rest of your three
news you guys are going to want to stay
tuned to games but thanks for watching